vous êtes 6 millions d'abonnés à ma
chaîne youtube merci beaucoup je je je
ne pouvais pas ne pas faire de vidéos
pour vous remercier ce n'est pas
concevoir que vous avez été très très
très nombreux à me demander la vidéo
cyprien répond à vos questions 4 et du
coup j'en fais pas vous êtes 6 millions
mais vous ne connaissez pas tant que ça
du coup on va corriger ça je vous
propose 20 choses sur moi j'ai pas ses
doigts désolés que vous ne connaissez
pas sauf si vous êtes ma maman j'ai un
grain de beauté en plein milieu du front
ce qui me donne un petit côté hindous ou
cible de snipers on sait pas attention
pas un truc sur le front là c'est normal
j'avais prévenu ces témoins 2 j'adore
dessiner c'est une de mes grandes
passions dans ma vie je dessine depuis
que je sais tenir un crayon d'ailleurs
si je n'ai pas fait de vidéos j'aurais
probablement fait des petites bd sur
internet
malheureusement je dessine de moins en
moins parce que j'ai de moins en moins
le temps ou en tout cas je me donne de
moins en moins de temps et j'ai ma
marque de tee shirt qui me force à être
régulier à faire des dessins
régulièrement 3 mes parents sont
roumains mais ça j'en parlerai dans une
prochaine vidéo car je suis né à nice et
j'ai grandi dans le var je monte sur
paris il ya sept ans est mort parce qu'à
chaque fois que je dis ça on me disait
assez marrante à part accent du sud
parce que tous ceux qui habitent sous
lion l'accent du sud c'est connu
absolument tout le monde sauf toi c'est
bizarre pas tous les sudistes ont un
accent voilà comme ça c'est dit puis
personnellement avec des parents qui ont
un accent roumain c'est compliqué de
choper un accent du sud ou alors à
l'accent du sud la roumanie grand max 5
j'adore les jouer quand je rentre dans
un magasin de jouets pour offrir un truc
un enfant je suis comme ça n'achète rien
n'achète rien je veux le buzz l'éclair
géant s'il vous plaît monsieur c'est une
statue de m elle n'est pas à vendre tu
la veux maintenant c'est je ne peux pas
manger de poisson ou de fruits de mer si
on m'en fait manger je fais ça même
l'odeur ça me suffit parce que si je
passe devant une poissonnerie même juste
parler de poisson là j'exagère un peu
mais deuxième prénom
j'en ai pas voilà souvent les deuxième
prénom c'est des prénoms bien
bien nul moi mes parents ils ont pensé à
me mettre directement en deuxième prénom
merci papa merci maman lui il est vrai
que j'ai un petit peu de mal avec la
cuisine si vous me regardez cuisiner
c'est assez triste
[Musique]
oh
ceci est mon quotidien mais attention je
sais faire ça et aussi sa également sa
merci beaucoup disent je n'ai pas le
permis
mais bon ça va c'est assez humiliant
comme ça on va pas en rajouter
merci je peux pour toi mais moi je suis
super nerveux au volant je suis super
nerveux et ou pas je me le dit jean
louis jean louis était nerveux au volant
voilà tout le monde au lit exactement
des deux chevaux comme ça je suis au
volant pas pu nerveux et wacip et un
abandon faussé par l moi c'est vraiment
pareil je suis super nerveux à la place
passager est ce que quelqu'un peut me
ramener ce soir peut-être je serai pas
nerveux place passager
j'ai une cicatrice sur le crâne je me
suis fait ça en tombant par terre quand
j'avais cinq ans c'était très douloureux
j'ai eu des points de suture et mais je
vous propose une petite reconstitution
[Musique]
tous je suis capable de passer des
journées entières sur mon ordinateur mon
téléphone
même s'il ne se passe rien bien sûr
twitter un lien sur facebook
13 je connais le chiffre pivi chiffres
après la virgule 3014 15 92 65 ça ne
sert à rien sauf si vous jouez à qui
veut gagner des millions et qu'on vous
pose la question vous m'appelez mon
numéro c'est le 03 14 15 92 25 14
quand j'étais petit mon doudou c'était
pas une peluche ou un chiffon non
c'était un oreiller que je trimballe est
absolument partout alors j'ai arrêté ça
commence à devenir contraignant mais
qu'on paie quoi ce soir on va en boîte
mais bon c'est parti
car quand j'étais gamin j'étais amoureux
de ondine du dessin animé pokémon oui
j'étais amoureuse d'un dessin animé
c'est pour ça que je ne vais pas dans
des conventions avec des cosplayers
d'ailleurs salut j'ai 13 ans aurore seul
j'adore qu'on me masse le crâne mais
vraiment d'écouter qu'on me touche la
tête même le visage ça m'endort
immédiate en mer sans poissons notamment
j'ai eu un problème avec la paperasse
dès qu'il faut envoyer un truc par la
poste vous pouvez être sûr que je ne le
ferai jamais ça va traîner toute une vie
sur mon bureau je suis tellement
fainéant que c'est un pote à moi qui a
envoyé les papiers à ma place pour faire
ma carte navigo 18 ma toute première
vidéo postée sur internet c'était un
test de jeux vidéo ouendan c'est parce
que c'est pas se prendre un choix pour
d'expliquer c'est un jeu nintendo ds ma
deuxième vie
2 posté sur internet une musique avec un
pote dans le garage chez mes parents
et ma dernière vidéo postée sur internet
celle-ci 19
ouais je m'attache pas aux objets même
si c'est des cadeaux ou des vêtements
dès que ça ne sert à rien ou des j'en ai
marre je le donne je le jette
et voilà mais le pire c'est les boîtes
où est ce qu'ils gardent leur boîte de
tablettes ou de téléphone vous peut-être
je sais pas moi
moi je comprends pas c'est le premier
truc que je jette cyprien qu'il simulait
les cartons des ordinateurs attaqués
deux pages pour s'occuper ce matin je
vais jeter y avait mon ordinateur dedans
je sais quoi ce point rouge et vin je
collectionne les fausses vidéos de moi
sur youtube dès que j'en vois une je
fais un screenshot
en fait c'est des mecs qui se font
passer pour moi sur youtube et qui pose
des fausses vidéos juste pour faire du
clic voici mon top 3 des vidéos que j'ai
jamais faite en troisième position
cyprien l'échappée revers avec 1,3
million bu pas mal en deuxième position
cyprien les roues avec 1,7 million de
vues on notera la description tetris
cd-rom vidéo de 2pm si quelqu'un a une
explication à ça et ma vidéo préféré que
je n'ai jamais réalisé
cyprien laisse un tueur avec seulement
sept cent soixante mille vies mais
mention spéciale pour le nom de la
chaîne beyoncé cyprien le mec s'est dit
c'est sur la sava doubleclick et en plus
les gens pensent que c'est la même
personne
ça va cliquer voilà maintenant vous
savez tout sur moi je vous remercie
encore de vous être abonné à ma chaîne
depuis le le garage de chez mes parents
jusqu'à aujourd'hui je prends toujours
autant de plaisir à faire des vidéos
j'ai encore plein de trucs à vous
raconter et pour moi vous êtes les
meilleurs abonnés du monde
merci beaucoup attention vous avez un
petit point rouge sont au front juste
[Musique]